gambling is very neurologically similar
gambling addiction to cocaine addiction
it's difficult for people to comprehend
i accept because it isn't a substance
and you think how do you get addicted to
something that isn't a substance how is
it having that effect on those
neurological pathways in the same way
cocaine does but but it's a
physiological addiction
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
director of cleanup gambling mad zab
cousin welcome to trigonometry thanks
for having me on uh it's great to have
you on listen before we get into talking
about what we're gonna talk about tell
everybody a little bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
your journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us oh well
i'm uh a campaigner for gambling reform
and i was addicted to gambling when i
was younger i got addicted to fixed odds
betting terminals from the age of 16
and
yeah got into a huge amount of debt and
had a profound impact on my my life when
i was young and my mental health
and then
thankfully
after that i
managed to get treatment and support and
got out of the addiction and
finished my degree and then went into
politics i worked for a couple of mps
and then
uh started campaigning against fixed
osbetting terminals when i was about 22
and that was a campaign that spanned
many years but we we got that over the
line and that was enacted in
2019 we campaigned for the maximum stake
to be reduced from 100 pounds down to
two pounds of spin
and since then um i've been
pushing for reforms of online gambling
so
a wide spectrum of different
uh policy areas that we're hoping to
address
uh but in the middle of all of that i i
was a spokesperson for jeremy corbyn
between 2016 and 2017. i'm off
we'll maybe talk about that towards the
end because we had a fascinating
conversation about it um
we were talking before and uh francis
was telling you that we've we've
obviously we've got advertisers that
advertise on our show
and
uh we'd never really had any big issue
with advertising various things that
were being offered but we got an a
suggestion of an ad for a gambling
company once
and the guys didn't particularly mind
but i don't know why i had a really
strong feeling
that i don't want to be advertising this
and i don't even necessarily i couldn't
formulate why
but i just i do think there's something
about it that you know like when you
were when you were addicted and you lost
all that money how much in the whole
were you
oh well i i was
about 20 000
down um by the age of 20 and it took me
quite a few years to pay it off um and
yeah so i mean that's the thing it has
quite
significant long-term medium-term
long-term consequences as well like you
can stop gambling but then you have all
of the
you're trying to pay back all the debts
and you're trying to repair all the
damage that has caused and that can take
a number of years as well so
yeah look i think your instincts are
probably right
like i think what people don't aren't
really aware of is
that the the business model is very much
uh
trying to extract as much as possible
from the people that become addicted
so
um for example between 60 and 80 of the
profits for online gambling are coming
from the five percent of people that are
either problem or at-risk gamblers so
the the vast majority of the revenues
are coming from people who are losing
more than they can afford
so when you've got a business model like
that
your core customer base that's driving
the majority of your revenue
is constantly going broke so you need to
replace it
so this is where the
huge spend on advertising comes in
and it's not just advertising on
podcasts and tv and you know digital ads
it's also affiliate marketing there's
some affiliates that will get between 50
and 75 percent of someone's losses if
they get someone to sign up to a
gambling site through them so they
didn't offer us that deal if they did we
definitely would have taken i mean
that would be very tempting i could
imagine yeah yeah so i mean that's the
thing is a constant like
clamor for player acquisition you need
new ads they need new people all the
time yeah because they're they're
customer-based that you know the average
um
account
lasts a year so a customer will have an
account on average for a year and in
that time they will either get addicted
and lose all the money they have access
to or they just get bored and there's
very few people in between
um there are people in between of course
and there'll be people watching this who
will bet occasionally but it's not those
people that bet every now and again
infrequently that are driving the
majority of the revenue it's not you
know that's not the reason that we have
10 premier league teams sponsored by
gambling companies you know that it's
the people that are losing
life life-altering sums of money
unfortunately matt and how do you know
this where do where do these stats come
from because what you've just said is is
horrific because essentially they've
found a way to monetize addiction
they have yeah i mean so there's various
different studies that the sixty percent
from five percent comes from the the
house of lords gambling industry select
committee and
there was an estimate recently from
natsen and gamble aware which i think it
was 86 percent coming from five percent
uh 86 of the profits coming from the
five percent of the customers so
lots of different estimates based on
different data that we have access to
different researchers have access to but
the overwhelming picture is that you
have a business model effectively that
relies on people losing more than they
can afford a subset of the customer base
and
in that context
it's not in their commercial interest to
reduce harm
if they reduce harm they're going to
reduce their profits and
that means you know that means that
they're going to have to stand up in
front of their shareholders and say this
next quarter we're going to reduce
addiction and we're going to reduce
profits as a result it's just not viable
it's not it's not possible for them to
do it through self-regulation so this is
why we push the regulations i think it's
a market that does need
regulation otherwise you just end up
with
uh
the vendor extracting as much as they
can from the consumer in that kind of
antagonistic relationship and why why
are you not pushing for complete
prohibition
i don't think prohibition works i think
it's better to have
a legal and regulated market
um
but properly regulated the problem we
have is we have a legal market but it
isn't properly regulated
it's a bit like if and and i think there
are some analogies with drug policy but
it's a bit like if we were to legalize
drugs which i would be very sympathetic
towards
and decided to
instead of you know regulating supply
and regulating consumption um we just
decided to liberalize the market
completely and allow
suppliers to advertise on tv and
had no limits to what you could purchase
and you know didn't invest properly in
treatment that's another problem that we
have as well with gambling so all of
these things you think well all the
benefits of having something that's
regulated
uh legalized and regulated properly are
being missed in gambling because we're
just not we're just not
um applying proper regulation to it matt
is in no there must be a body that
regulates the gambling industry
there is the gambling commission and the
gambling commission was conceived of in
the early 2000s and and was
formed
after the 2005 gambling act
it took the gambling commission seven
years to start licensing online gambling
so that was basically a wild west for
seven years when from 2007 when the
gambling commission was formed to 2014
and ever since then it's been playing
catch up so effectively you had you've
had these online gambling operators
that
all went offshore to tax havens so
they're not paying corporation tax
built their businesses up with in low
tax low regulation jurisdictions
and were able to sell gambling their
services to the british market without
any oversight for so long
and
as i say the gambling commission ever
since has been playing catch up but the
problem is that the legislation the
gambling act is
it's not really geared towards
regulating online gambling it's mainly
focused on venue-based gambling which is
what we had in the early 2000s internet
gambling was very
very primitive at that point so
i think yeah that's one of the things
we're trying to do is just bring that
legislation into the 21st century and uh
from the from the point of view of the
sort of addiction itself
most people i think watching this will
have had the experience of smoking or
drinking a bit too much or taking drugs
or whatever addictions that people have
i think almost everyone can relate to
the process of being addicted to
something in some one way or another
is gambling similar or is it a different
thing entirely
uh gambling is very neurologically
similar gambling addiction to cocaine
addiction so there's been various
studies on how it affects the brain now
it's difficult for people to comprehend
i accept because it isn't a substance
and you think how do you get addicted to
something that isn't a substance how is
it having that effect on
those neurological pathways in the same
way cocaine does but but it's a
physiological addiction and i think that
when you're looking at something like
gambling addiction for a long time
it suited the gambling industry to
propagate an argument that
and this fits in with the kind of
responsible gambling paradigm where like
if people get addicted it's because
they've got something wrong with them
like they're they're faulty individuals
and you know
we need to just look after this very
small percentage of people that for some
reason get addicted to gambling
and that's not really
evidence an evidence-based perspective
and the reality is that you have
particular gambling products that are
much more associated with gambling
addiction than others so for example
online slots
45 of people that engage with online
slots are either problem or at risk
gamblers so
yeah compare that fixed betting
terminals was around fifty percent
what's a fixed i'd be betting terminal
mac just for clarification yeah so
that's a machine in a betting shop where
you can bet you used to be able to bet
up to 100 pounds every 20 seconds on
roulette and
wow yeah um
and we reduced that to two pounds of
spin in in 2019 so that was obviously a
very welcome change
but i think the um
yeah i think the understanding
that gambling products can have a role
in inducing or exacerbating gambling
harm
uh you know that that was recognized
with that policy change and i think that
that now needs to be applied to
to different products online at the
moment there's no limits to the stakes
on online slots for example so that's
this is a people the amount people can
lose is limitless
and it can happen very quickly and
unlike with other addictions as you
mentioned
it's so easy to keep gambling addiction
a secret there's no physical signs
or no obvious physical signs
people can
feel as though
that by gambling they can
win their way out of trouble they can
actually solve the problems their
addiction has caused by carrying on with
the thing they're addicted to which is
quite i think unique
compared to drinking or drugs
so yeah i mean it's incredibly dangerous
for many reasons and the the harms
extend beyond the individual very often
it's families that will
will you know bear the brunt of
someone's gambling and
workplaces and communities if people
steal from work to fund their addiction
so there's a huge knock-on effect and at
the middle of it you've got a sector
which is kind of reaping the rewards at
the expense of everyone else
while being based in
primarily based in tax havens
and you think well this is an obvious
kind of area for that needs regulation
yeah and one of the questions i i was
going to ask is i think i've been in the
casino i think twice in my life
and i found it
quite a scary experience in some ways
because i remember
i had this chip in my hand
uh that was worth hundred quid or 200
quid
it did not feel like
what i was placing on the table was a
hundred pounds worth because a hundred
pounds is a lot of money particularly in
that moment it was a lot of money to me
but
it just it changed the experience and i
imagine gambling online does that even
more it doesn't feel like real money
people often say about credit cards
when they spend money on a credit card
it doesn't feel like real money is that
part of of the process where there's a
kind of disassociation from reality of
how much money you're playing with and
gambling away
yeah absolutely the disassociation is
very much a part of it um
and yeah online obviously
there's the propensity to have repeat
deposits you can deposit money into an
online gambling account there's no real
checks you can just keep depositing as
much as you can as much as you want to
um and before you know it you've lost
all your money because you've been in
that cycle of loss chasing
and yeah it's a huge there's a huge
disassociative effect with online
gambling and we are the first generation
that
has access to
casino games at high speed in our
pockets
historically
you know there was one point in europe
where roulette was banned everywhere and
the only place you could play it was
monte carlo
because there was a recognition that it
was an addictive game an addictive
product
and of course you know it's better to
have access to roulette and allow it to
be played in a legal and regulated
environment
um
for people that want to play it but
the idea that this should be on every
device that everyone walks around with
and there shouldn't be any limits to the
amount people can gamble
um and no stake limits and no real
checks
uh it's a dangerous experiment and i
think that unfortunately you know we're
starting to see the results of it and
matt what how do you know if you're
developing an addiction to gambling
because i think most people would know
by looking at someone that they're
developing an addiction to booze but
like you said on the surface someone
could potentially be a gambling addict
and you'd be none the wiser
yeah absolutely i think um this i mean
if if you're looking for signs in others
i think if someone you know is like
never seems to have any money or is
withdrawn and not coming out as much
um i think that's a that's a sign like
but you really do have to read between
the lines it's so easy i mean i say it's
easy i i've been never been in that
position myself where i was became very
good at lying because i tried to conceal
it and you do it because you think
you're protecting other people in a way
like you think i don't want people to
worry about me so i will you know keep
this to myself
um but really you know
you need help and i think
recognizing that if you're in that cycle
of loss chasing if you're
gambling is becoming a preoccupation
and you're constantly thinking about
your next bet that's when it's starting
to become an addiction and you know i
think that that point
is like good to kind of reflect on that
and
um seek help if you if you need to and
you want to because there is help
available
uh and you can get out of it and it's
better to do it early as well
i mean the problem at the moment with
the regulations is
it is it's still a bit of a wild west so
you that that it's like exponential
curve addiction gambling addiction
you start
gambling maybe sporadically
then you'll start getting really into it
and then you'll be gambling more than
you thought you would ever start
gambling
uh and then before you know it you have
a session or two where you've lost way
more than you
had planned to or can afford to and then
you're chasing losses and then you've
cleaned out your bank account and you
think how the hell did that happen so it
can happen very quickly
and it's a bit like if you start
if you start drinking
if you start having a few pints when
you're in the middle of that drinking
session
you
your judgment is obviously different to
before you started
and
it's the same with gambling once you
start gambling when you're in that
gambling session
it does affect your decision making
so yeah this is why i think you know
it's a really good idea to have proper
limits before you start and do the does
gambling tend to come with other
addictions like do people tend to
develop a gambling addiction plus
alcoholism or does it live most often on
its own
there are comorbidities but i think that
i mean there are plenty of examples of
people that get addicted to just
gambling and
yeah i think that um
one might lead to the other in certain
circumstances but yeah i think the
gambling addiction ought to be treated
separately to
to other addictions it's not this person
is an addict you know there are
different things are happening in the
brain with different addictions
when you were comparing it to cocaine
isn't it more similar to compare it to
pornography addiction
in a way i'm not sure but i don't know
much about it pornography addiction but
i think you were speaking neurologically
when you were talking about cocaine yeah
yeah
yeah i mean quite quite
quite possibly um it
but yeah neurologically that's it that
it was that research on the parallels of
cocaine addiction that shifted there's
something called the diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders
dsm
and from dsm-4 to dsm-5 it moved
gambling from an impulse control
disorder which i think is where
pornography sits still
to
an addiction on a par with drugs and
alcohol
when we had david nutt on the show to
talk about we francis was asking about
what predisposes people to alcoholism
one of the things she said is there's
clearly a genetic component or
potentially a genetic component because
one of the strongest predictors
particularly for men of being addicted
to alcohol is a father who's an
alcoholic
uh has there been any research on what
might predispose someone to being
addicted to gambling
yeah i think there are factors certainly
um i mean the genetic question is
interesting i think that that could also
be behavioral conditioning it could be
that you're taking cues from that parent
yeah there's lots of examples of
of parents taking their children to the
races when they're young you know and
they have that good experience and that
stays with them and
um and that can manifest itself in
different ways as you get older but
there has definitely been a lot of
research into
into that i think it's difficult to
determine
um my from my perspective like
yes there may be
you may be more vulnerable to gambling
addiction if you have a pre-existing
mental health condition you know if you
have anxiety or if you have other mental
health problems
um but
the thing that we can actually control
is the regulation of gambling so that's
always been my focus i mean we can't do
much about people's genetic
predispositions but what we can do is
regulate the industry and if there are
particular products that are associated
with gambling harm
then you know it's best to focus on
those
so if you were gonna
introduce regulation what would you
actually do matt
so there's a few things i'd do i mean
as i mentioned before
the
um
the gambling legislation at the moment
was conceived of a time before kind of
internet gambling really took off
and in that legislation there are
provisions to regulate stakes and prizes
on machines and that's one of the things
that we changed with fixed us betting
terminals from 100 pounds down to two
pounds of spin
and i think that this this needs to be
similar controls on
the same content online so slots for
example there needs to be a limit of two
pounds of spin as there is on
easily accessible machines in different
gambling venues
and
i think as well as that i'd like to see
restrictions on advertising around
football
i mean i think there's an argument to
end all gambling advertising
of the industry in its current form
given the way it's currently constituted
but i can see that why people would
argue for kind of carve outs for racing
on tv when you know that televised
racing kind of depends on gambling ads
i would
put more money into treatment and
research independent research
through a levy on the industry
i'd like to see an ombudsman at the
moment if you get um i mean this is
it's astonishing really this is allowed
to to happen but if you're not paid out
by a gambling operator or you're treated
particularly unfairly
there's no consumer ombudsman so they
can just
take your money and that's it
and on very many occasions they've done
this they've also
been able to because of use of big data
and how that's kind of permeated into
book making and
the operation of gambling uh commercial
gambling
they're able to kind of predict whether
you are
going to be a winning gambler so on
products like slots and roulette
mathematically impossible to win in the
long term
but in theory you could
win in the longer term playing betting
on
racing or football if you had an edge
over the bookmaker or i don't know
table tennis or something you know
but if if they're able to be able to
predict that within quite frightening
accuracy
based on your betting patterns initially
how much you're going to win or lose
over a 12-month period
and if you're not going to be profitable
to them then they will restrict your
account or close your account and
they're allowed to do that and there are
very many examples of people who haven't
even been making a huge amount of money
whose bets get restricted down to
10p 20p just because
they're going to win
so
what people need to be aware of is
you can't win and there is no provision
or mechanism for consumer address
so if you want to complain to someone
you can complain to the gambling
commission and they might take
enforcement action if there's
a breach of the license conditions but
they're not going to advocate on your
behalf so this is why we need a gambling
ombudsman
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one-on-two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
and uh let's explore some of the counter
arguments a little bit because we
haven't done that yet so
one of the things is one of the things
people might say is well i agree with
you gambling is designed in a way that
you can't win right over the long term
but
people might say it's the same reason
why people buy lottery tickets they're
not actually buying a lottery ticket
because they think statistically
speaking this is the best investment of
money
to to grow their portfolio it's because
they enjoy the experience of thinking
they might win so you're not buying a
win you're buying the emotional
experience of oh i could win
um so
is isn't isn't that quite a reasonable
thing for people to pay for that
experience if you like yeah i think this
is i completely agree i don't i wouldn't
even say that was necessarily a counter
argument to what i'm trying to say is
it's actually
that's true and it is
i think it is for many people a form of
entertainment yeah and is a legitimate
form of entertainment
the
problems start when
that form of entertainment
starts costing people their rent money
and starts costing families you know
christmas presents and you know all
sorts of knock-on effects from gambling
that is supposed to be entertainment and
you know the gambling industry has been
quite resistant to the idea of
affordability checks for people who are
losing you know significant sums of
money
but if it is an entertainment product if
it is something like
equivalent to going to the cinema or you
know whatever people do for fun these
days i don't know i don't really have
much fun
you can tell you used to work for jeremy
um
yeah then you know the
the kind of money that's spent on it
should arguably be in that kind of
ballpark you can't lose 20 grand at the
cinema i get it what about um
you know
the inevitable comparison with alcohol
or whatever like this point the 80 20
rule which is 20 the customers provide
80 of the profits that's how it is in
almost every business it'll be the same
with trigonometry 20 percent of probably
far fewer than 20 percent of our
viewership will send 80 of the of the
money that we use to fund the show right
so
um in terms of that isn't that the case
with everything with alcohol like
the people who could provide a lot of
the profits for alcohol
con businesses would be
people who drink a lot inevitably right
so that's kind of the case everywhere
yeah i think 80 20 would be an
improvement on the current status quo
with gambling i mean it's it's about as
i said it's about 86 five at the moment
so
it does rely significantly on and and in
that five it's not these people really
like gambling i mean some of them might
but like it's predominantly people who
are losing more than they can afford and
actually not having a great time right
so
i think that that's a yeah a factor
and what would you think about the
argument matter of people going which is
a more dare i say libertarian argument
which is look
people are adults
if people want to do that then they're
going to do that you know
we live in a free society people are
going to make stupid choices stupid
decisions and that's their
responsibility as an adult to do that
yeah i think that there is
i mean like
personally speaking i do take
responsibility i had to for my recovery
and and like no one's going to recover
from my gambling addiction for me um so
yeah obviously there is
there is that there is that element
but i think what we don't talk about is
the responsibility of like the gambling
industry and the responsibility of other
other actors in society like the
government and the regulator is it fit
for purpose is it doing its job properly
and
from my perspective up there not being
responsible and
yeah
individual responsibility can only take
you so far i also think like because you
get this free market argument as well
uh which is kind of linked to that
libertarian argument
and
i do think that gambling is quite unique
in uh it does
cut across some of the logic of the
market
because in other sectors of the economy
it is in the interests of the vendor or
you know the the sector itself providing
the service
to do so in a way that the consumer um
likes and wants to you know return to
uh to do so at a cost that's you know
palatable to the individual
but in gambling there is an antagonism
between the consumer and the vendor the
vendor wants to
screw the consumer right so you in that
context the market doesn't work the
market logic doesn't really apply
i think that's why when we started the
conversation that was my hesitation
about gambling because i feel
and look i haven't explored this
argument in nearly enough detail to be
able to say this is my opinion but
instinctively my feeling was this is a
uniquely exploitative industry
which really wants to
extract all the profit it can from
individuals and there's absolutely no
intention for that to be a long-term
relationship of any kind even a drug
dealer wants you to keep coming back
whereas from based on what you're saying
is it's more like let's get all your
money get you bankrupt and then we'll
get another someone else yeah but here's
another counter argument that i always
think about because i definitely have a
very addictive personality um and the
way i've learned to regulate that for me
is i just force myself to get addicted
to good things
right so rather than being addicted to
alcohol or
uh you know computer games or whatever
which i i enjoy i enjoy playing my games
i enjoy having a drink every now and
again but it's never been
that way addictive for me i try to get
addicted to building this to be the best
youtube show that it can be uh to when i
was doing comedy and i did go quite far
in terms of you know undermining my
relationships and stuff but still what
my point is
i feel
that no and i've done lots of personal
development and all that sort of thing i
don't believe that i will never be
i will i will ever get to a point where
i don't find things addictive
and so i've always thought that
like addiction quite often
you can you can deal with someone who's
gambling let's say but if gambling
wasn't available to them they'd probably
find something else do you see what i'm
saying is that another argument i know
what you mean and
someone who's become addicted to
gambling they may replace it with
something else right but but
it's
it's that void that you replace you're
filling that void
with something that you hope would be
more productive and more rewarding for
that individual i mean gambling is not a
rewarding endeavor and the time spent on
gambling
uh particularly if you're addicted to it
um you know it's
you don't get that time back and that's
one of the things that
everyone who have known who's been
addicted to gambling has lamented more
than money that they've lost is you know
the the fact that they've because of
their because of their addiction that
they have lost
the time that not been they've not been
present
and i think that
you here now you're very present you're
very present in the in what you're doing
and and obviously you've developed this
podcast and you've obviously achieved a
lot and that's because of your
focus and what gambling does is it
strips you of that
and it's a very different type of
you're immersed in it in a very
different way to work and i say that as
someone who is equally as obsessed with
my work yeah yeah yeah the reason i'm
asking this question it came out very
muddled and that's because you're the
first person we've really spoken about
this so i haven't thought these
arguments through very much but i guess
what i'm saying is i i there's a part of
me that sort of cringes a little bit
when when we talk about personal
responsibility and we're like no no it's
the industry that needs to because to me
at the end of the day
there will always be something that you
as an individual can be addicted to
exploited by etc
and until we all start to go well what
can i do about this
there's always going to be something out
there and if it's okay maybe you can
regulate gambling people will get
addicted to other things that exist out
there computer games porn drugs whatever
um so that was that was the reason i'm
asking the question i feel like yeah i
do feel like there's more as an
individual that you can do
um and i think forgive me for saying
this uh on the left particularly and i'm
someone who has views from all over the
political spectrum
there's
not enough
of you need to take responsibility for
yourself and there's too much of the
system is to blame
and i'm hearing a little bit of that and
hence the the sort of the question do
you see what i'm saying that's what
you're saying yeah i think that um there
is always a role for personal
responsibility of course there is and
people
um
yeah people
who
get who are addicted to gambling might
be listening to this or watching this
you know hearing me say
well the industry is not properly
regulated and you know the harm that
they've experienced might have been
reduced by better regulation it's not
going to help them in this particular
moment
what might help them is
reaching out to
the national gambling helpline to the
nhs clinics for problem gambling
to
gam stop to gamban which is blocking
software i co-founded if you don't mind
plugging it in
ganban.com um
that might help them in that moment and
yes they do have to take responsibility
for their recovery no one is going to do
that for them
but i think if we're going to try to
reduce
gambling addiction i'm not talking about
all addictions but gambling addiction
and gambling harm and the harm that it
causes
then there are i believe things we can
do in terms of regulation and that's not
me saying
there's no role for individual
responsibility or blaming it all on the
industry i'm just sort of saying
what are the things practical things we
can do and i believe that these are the
things we can do you know what i'm a big
football fan uh i was gonna say like you
are but you're an arsenal fan so you
don't really like football sorry i'll
get that dig in immediately but
and look i tend to be quite libertarian
i think over lockdown i've become even
more libertarian with these demented
policies that have been brought in and i
watch the football thanks for keeping
the neutral down there
that's what is what we do here and by
watching football and i'm watching west
ham
and then during the interval i just get
bombarded with gambling after gambling
advert after gambling advert and being
someone who used to teach and teach you
know kids of 10 and 11 and also in
secondary school kids love football
particularly boys aren't we just
indoctrinating them when they're seeing
their you know their favorite football
team sponsored by gambling adverts when
they're watching the football and it's
gambling advert after gambling advert
ray winston coming out
isn't this
quite
the word big fan of
yeah
not immoral but
i do believe that it's almost
indoctrinating them isn't it yeah
there's a conditioning element to it and
there was research in australia that
found that you know kids
as young as six who had quite
significant recollection of gambling
brands and how to place a bet and what
odds meant lots of children growing up
now there's other research that shows
that they think that
placing a bet is part of supporting a
team so
yes we're storing up i think some
problems or challenges for the future
with children growing up in this
environment because it is it's the first
generation to do so
so yeah i think that isn't that is an
issue i mean i think it's more of an
issue given how the industry is
currently constituted because you think
well
what's the problem with kids growing up
with you know being bombarded with
gambling apps and all that sort of stuff
and the problem is that when they turn
18 and they are able to download these
apps and deposit money is that they are
at that most their most vulnerable point
particularly young men more young men
are
addicted to gambling between the ages of
18 to 24 than any other demographic so
so it's that it's the fact that the
industry is constituted in such a way
that once the
it needs people to get addicted and you
have a very vulnerable demographic who
has a right of passage almost in the
same way that perhaps when we
turned 18 we went well to the pub and
had our first legal point um
they're downloading all the gambling
apps so i mean that's not something that
i even experienced i was gambling on the
machines obviously i was already
addicted by 18 but
i didn't have a smartphone that didn't
exist then so like
yeah it's it's it's just
it's difficult to know what the impact
is going to be but the the signs are
that it's having a quite a significant
negative impact and the lockdown kind of
helped either that must have seen
problem gambling going through the roof
because people sat at home all day
you know access to these apps i mean
that must have seen profits spike for
the gambling companies yeah it did they
had record profits during lockdowns and
um like for example online slots
increased by 30 during the first
lockdown so substantial increases and
yeah profits increased despite the
cancellation of sports fixtures in
lockdown one so like just shows like the
shift to the more kind of addictive
products and
yeah i mean it did have a profound
profound effect and um
it's accelerated the switch from
venue-based gambling to online gambling
which is why i think the government's
review which is ongoing at the moment
and we're expecting hopefully the white
paper to be published in april
it's why it's kind of so important that
the focus on online gaming regulation
i'm curious uh because
now
the gambling culture exists in russia
not nearly in the same way that but when
i was growing up in the soviet union it
wasn't really a thing that people did uh
but in this country as a for as an
outsider i can see it's a huge part of
the culture
right you go to the game you have a
little cheeky bet you go to the races
you have a bet like it's part of
it's been around i'm guessing for for
centuries did you do you have an insight
into as to why that is why this culture
particularly is has that embedded in it
so strongly
you mean like the link between sports
but just a bet in general is something
that is not the same in other countries
you know yeah it's interesting i i don't
know what the origins are um but yeah it
is definitely something that's it's
always been part of you know the
experience the match day experience you
know or obviously guys that racing
wouldn't racing and betting coexist you
know the mutu
you couldn't have one without the other
so it's always been a part of our
culture it's always been a part of of
that experience but
you know i'm not saying that that
shouldn't be the case yeah you just want
to regulate it that that's it and and
you know it's a
i think
it's there's a spectrum of
prohibition which obviously i'm not in
favor of
uh promotion and liberalization
and
tolerating something and you know
returning to this principle of
unstimulated demand is saying that if
people want to do it they're going to do
it they should do it in a regulated and
safe
environment but should we be encouraging
it or promoting it to the extent that we
are i'm not saying that necessarily that
shouldn't be permitted you know race
tracks or whatever
but there's just a conversa i think a
grown-up conversation to be had about
like where it sits between these two
between like unstimulated demand and
promotion
and uh
yeah i mean reformers gambling reformers
like me
often caricatured in some ways like
prohibitionist because we want to have
more regulation
and i think that that kind of
is unhelpful because it
i think really yeah that's where the
debate is is being had and that's
thankfully what the debate the
government's kind of willing to have as
well
well we really appreciate you coming on
thank you so much for that it's been a
great chat uh tell everybody uh where
they can go if they if they've got an
issue with gambling if they want to
support the work that you're doing etc
yeah if you've got an issue with
gambling go to
talkbandstop.com and there's
lots of information on there and free
advice and support and you can get
ganban for free through talkbandstop.com
and if you're interested in the gambling
reform work that i'm doing then
cleanupgambling.com and there's
stuff on there about
what we're campaigning for and there's a
template letter to mps and all that sort
of stuff so if you want to get involved
that'd be great and yeah by all means
get in touch i'm happy to hear from
anyone all right fantastic thank you so
much uh guys thank you so much for
watching and listening well we're gonna
ask matt a couple of very special
questions from you for our locals only
but in the meantime we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode like
this one or raw show all of them go out
at 7 pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
people on the left are like why you
still remember the labour party why
still why would you vote for labour
party the reason i would vote for it is
to destroy
[Music]
[Music]